wer würde als erster fahrer der würde er
etwas aus dem zimmer des anderen clown
wer würde er seine mutter geld klauen
herzlich willkommen sollten wir heute
habt es euch gewünscht deswegen ist es
jetzt hier für euch ein neues video
zusammen mit meinen geschwistern meinte
er zu meiner linken und hier mein bruder
max leute wie spielt eine neue runde
werde die er unsere mutter ist hinter
der kamera würde als er sagte wir haben
hier auf unseren wie ich übrigens das
von meiner mutter nicht wundern über die
hülle unsere namen und je nachdem wie es
ist wenn wir das aus und dank 21 wegen
habt ihr gewalt wir müssen gleich mal
ganz kurz
so ist es besser gar keine ahnung
max der der beziehungsmensch in der als
sowieso als ich hoffe ich hoffe mir du
hast noch nicht keinen kontakt zu jungs
da geht doch nicht in der anderen oder
[Gelächter]
ist das ganze am ende was wir zu sagen
ist das akkurat s-max der der amira und
china interessiert mich sehr
im ersten kind von max
das kann ja schon mal nicht ich sein
wurde die frage gestellt was sie
zufällig generiert ich hier ja eher
würde er etwas aus dem zimmer des
anderen klauen
das ist gut so
ein beispiel in der vergangenheit schon
gar nicht die frage ist wirklich so
schwer bringt gehirn zu hat bericht vor
dieser wetterfront alte leute hier in
der scharfen burg bei unserer film
geburtstag gefeiert hatte einige leute
ich hab natürlich nicht so viele und
hatte danach noch ein paar getränke über
die haben doch hier um gestanden und
dann bin ich wieder gefeiert getränk
auch hier stehen das unter anderem auch
drei wodkaflaschen oder so ich komme
zwei wochen später wieder hat er einfach
eine von meinen flaschen andere freundin
von ihr
wie kann man fremdes eigentum
verschenken an unseren jugendlichen
alkohol verkaufen würde er eine biedere
eine biene wieder beleben sollte unsere
mutter ist nicht so dass wir keine drei
bienen sind wichtig bei 21 lüge ja ja ja
ja aber ich bin auch sehr tierlieb
ich bin viel tierliebe hast du wissen
und nach bis er seit kurzem du hast
schon vorgemacht
ja man ja wohl okay alles da 321 weil er
meistens
und ich habe nicht viel machen lassen
muss jemand sein der sich nicht schön
für sie schwierig ok alles klar 3 2 1
das gefühl du hast überhaupt keinen
namen trage ja ich wollte auch keinen
verein heute diplomatisch ich hab' ich
hab dich aber weil ich glaube was gibt's
denn was man als mann als operation
überhaupt machen kann nase aber das ist
in augen ja irgendwie brustmuskeln
einsetzen aber das ja genauso marxheim
und auch geisteskranke brustmuskel weil
ich glaube also ich würde sagen das ist
ja eher so ein ding was er bei frauen
stattfinden wenn man sich mal die zahlen
anschauen will deswegen statistisch
wahrscheinlich würde ich sagen die nld
geplant habe ja was deine begründung du
willst einfach können oder würde er
seiner mutter geld klauen kann man also
auf ein bild als ob es nur um den betrag
ist ich habe immer so an dem sekretär
oben so die euro stücke des neg so aber
nicht nicht so ein sch ein bisschen
money genommen aber maximal 3
die wissen die bin der könig in der die
willkommen wenn du ohne mit der wimper
zu zucken eine flasche wodka oder einen
pulli oder sonst was nimmst wie fern
liegt es dass wir ohne mit der wimper zu
zucken 50 euro scheinen zu können so gar
nicht
also muss sehr hart aber ehrlich würde
ich zustimmen
ich muss sagen ich glaube ich glaube ich
das meiste geld gemacht habe mal einen
urlaub über einfach alle paar tage so 20
euro aus dem portmonee jetzt aber nicht
gefeit
alle paar tage so 20 euro das ist
einfach nicht gemerkt dass schlagen wenn
ihr von einer klaren wortlaut im urlaub
wie geht das ich war es dort nicht
weiter so würde er eine schlägerei
anfangen müsste ich auch ganz klar die
antworten ich auch ja drei zwei eins
meins zwar gut gemeint wir haben alle
und ich hätte ich hätte ganz klar
sebastian würde sie anfangen aber ich
würde sie beenden wir würden uns alle
nicht mal werden alle niemanden habe
nicht mehr das haben wir uns selbst
wissen alles sehr friedlich
die menschen aber ich würde eigentlich
provozieren e mails noch andere leute so
würde er sich essen holen ohne den
anderen was mitzubringen
das ist das ist eine schwierige frage
ja ok angst a3 gespannt ob das überhaupt
sehen kann
du sagst mag es zwar fährt zuhört zu ok
meine begründung sebastian und ich haben
eine stärkere verbindung zu essen
wir wissen gemeinsam wirklich wie es ist
wenn man nicht essen kann und du du hast
einfach dieses mitgefühl gegenüber es
nicht und deswegen finde ich eher
wahrscheinlich hat dass du uns nichts
mitbringen und das war somit der bringen
wir vielleicht nicht ich bin kein es gar
keinen sinn ich würde sagen also die
mama sagen ich hab ja das problem
ich habe einfach kein geld aber nur geld
hat ist auch das problem ist ich hab ja
ist genauso eine chaotin welchen chaot
war aber ich bin 19 jahre älter als du
ja das bedeutet das heißt ich habe schon
zehn jahre zeit gehabt und das so
langsam auszugleichen und da wäre noch
nicht wer von uns denkst du hat mehr
butterbrotdosen verloren in seinem leben
du wer von euch würde
kleine kinder so richtig erschrecken
dass sie richtig heulen und fertig sind
ich finde
max hat am ehesten ich weiß auch gar
nicht mal dass ich die leute findet max
hat am ehesten noch teilweise so ein
böses elementen waren also nicht nicht
böse so aber in dem sinne dass er auch
schon mal irgendwie manchmal so idee hat
so jetzt hab ich einfach irgend eine
person ab oder so weil also eine sache
die ich zum beispiel gar nicht ob da hat
ja auch nicht max die teilweise so
vergnügen daraus heute zu beobachten die
so lost sind also leute die so koppelt
am leben vorbei gehen die zieht mag sich
so helen verluste geschickt wird dann so
deren bilder von freunden erlaubt sich
daran dass das würde ich halt machen
habt dabei empfinde ich es bemerkt
vorgemerkt niemand aus dem engeren
umfeld also leute die auf tik tok los
sind ja so
aber jetzt nicht nur wer selbst ein kind
austragen kann sondern wer als erstes
kind bekommt er über dürften eine frau
würde er für ein monat gar nicht mehr
ans handy geht alles klar danach ja 321
das schon mal mehrere monate deshalb
könnte ich mir auch vorstellen das erste
macht und sich so selbst zu beweisen
aber ich nehme es mir bei mir gar nicht
vorstellen mag es am ehesten vorstellen
ich bin so krank handy süchtig leute ich
hab ich hab meine mutter zwar gab man
endlich kann ich nicht sagen aber ich
hab so durchschnittlich zehn stunden
handy am tag
ja ich glaub ich arbeite auch viel mit
dem handy so ins tavola aber zehn
stunden das ist nicht mehr normal und
ganz ehrlich leute für alle von euch die
auch sehr viel am handy sind passt mal
auf was das mit eurem kopf macht weil
ich glaube meine konzentrations und
erinnerungsfähigkeit bleibt extrem
herunter ja also das was du bald mit
einer neuen rolle werde mit meinen
geschwistern es war richtig heiß muss
sagen habe ich viel spaß damit dass auch
zunehmend ich glaube ich will das ganze
auch mit gefallen vorstellungsvideo
jährige bekam